i want to tell you about something we've
been working on
it's a new series effectively a
documentary series longer form
journalism called tucker carlson
originals the debut of the very first
episode is tomorrow you can see it first
thing in the morning it's on
foxnation.com
now the first episode is called crisis
in chicago and the basis
of this documentary are thousands of
hours of never
before seen footage from surveillance
cameras in the city of chicago
we got this we went through it for
months
and it presents a remarkable picture of
what's actually happening
unfiltered in the city of chicago one of
our great cities
the core of the story is a woman called
kim fox she's a prosecutor get elected
with help of george soros
and she has really changed chicago it's
been one of the most dangerous places
in the western hemisphere here's a
preview of it
the prosecutors are funded by a soros
back foundation called the justice and
public safety pack
it's directed by a person called whitney
thymus prosecutors
have more power and greater discretion
to impact the system really than anyone
including judges the plan is working in
her first year chicago's top prosecutor
kim fox dropped charges against nearly
30 percent of felony defendants
look at our justice system and ask
ourselves are we
satisfied with the system you can't take
an oath to be a prosecutor
and then turn around and undermine that
oath there aren't the consequences that
there used to be
some of the tape in that piece which i'm
not sure we can show on cable tv but you
can get it digitally on fox nation
is jaw-dropping see it you'll find out
anyway that's premiere episode of tucker
carlson originals
foxnation.com starting tomorrow morning
and tomorrow night right here
on this show we will be coming from the
fox studios lot in la to premiere
our entire first season of that series
it's an exclusive look at all the
episodes we're working on
by the way if you have trouble getting
to fox nation we'll show you exactly how
we'll go through it in detail